oh do not there is no try
sighs magic net look at me that's me by
my size do you
for my Ally is the force and Nepal for
colleges life bleeds it makes it grow
its energy surrounds us and binds us
illness beam so we not this crude matter
you must feel the force around you you
treat you everywhere welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is gonna be
my video all about Yoda's species on the
mandalorian and in the Star Wars Canon
because this is taking place right after
Return of the Jedi so a lot of people
are wondering if it's going to connect
with stuff that's happening during the
new trilogy in rise of Skywalker I am
doing videos for all the Mandalorian
episodes so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything
we're also doing a Star Wars merge
giveaway too so obviously careful for
spoilers from the Mandalorian if you
haven't seen it yet
Lucasfilm technically lifted the spoiler
ban on talking about baby Yoda but
that's basically what it was people were
just waiting till after the first couple
of weeks to start openly talking about
and posting pictures of baby Yoda but
just to be clear even though the
Internet has largely dubbed this person
baby Yoda we don't know that he is the
biological child of Yoda we don't know
that he's a clone of Yoda but I'll
discuss that during the video so this
scene is all about the Mandalorian being
saved by the young link that we're
dubbing baby Yoda and during a big
callback to Yoda lifting Luke's x-wing
out of the swamp and Empire Strikes Back
saves the Mandalorian from being crushed
by the mud horn creature by lifting it
in the air with the force then stunning
it when it drops to the ground long
enough for the Mandalorian to finish him
off baby Yoda promptly passes out
because the effort taxes him so much
you're basically using your life force
to do stuff like this which is why Luke
Skywalker died in the attempt to project
himself across the galaxy to help give
the resistance
time to get away baby Yoda is 50 years
old according to what they're saying on
the TV show that makes him around four
five years old in human years assuming
that he ages at about the same rate but
he can't quite talk so the planet kind
of fast and loose in terms of how fast
he develops relative to other races
because he can climb out of his hovering
bassinet he can walk on two legs he can
capture an e food by himself like we see
when he snarfs down that giant frog
relative to his size the Frog is almost
as big as he is then he's also able to
tell when the Mandalorians in trouble
he's able to use the force to sense
what's going on with them even though he
himself can't speak yet the only other
two members of his race that we've ever
met anywhere in the Star Wars universe
in any kind of Canon even the legends
Canon or Yoda himself who was about 900
years old when he died then yeah ttle
who we last saw during Phantom Menace
and she was a little under 500 years old
when that happened there's a story about
what happens to her after this moment
but they killed her off during the
legends timeline and even though that
isn't canon anymore she was actually
just referenced again during Star Wars
fallen order if you've been playing that
game they reference the adil in passing
during it someone thinks that she's
still alive out there somewhere but
that's it George Lucas has always
refused a lot of questions about Yoda's
backstory where his race comes from
things about his people like you would
normally ask questions about the other
races of the galaxy he's been very
meticulous in at least working with
other third parties in building out the
backstories behind all these cultures in
the galaxy but when it comes to Yoda
species it's a hard pass the only time
he's ever allowed or given his blessing
to creating a new member of the race is
during the Mandalorian species that
might be because Dave Filoni is working
on the show and he sort of George
Lucas's adoptive son George Lucas no
joke
thinks of Dave Filoni as the son that he
never had because George Lucas only has
daughters but a lot of people are now
wondering if this baby oda if he
survives the Mandalorian series which it
sounds like he will if he's going to be
the future of the Jedi Order for the
next 850 years which takes it way past
the rise of Skywalker and because of
some Easter eggs from Episode one on
Doctor Pershing's Imperial uniform there
are a lot of theories about who he is
and what the Empire's plans for baby
yoda are so if you missed this during
episode one dr. Pershing is wearing a
white Imperial medical officer's uniform
with a special symbol on it that denotes
the cloning facility a Camino from
Attack of the Clones
implying that he worked in cloning
research for the Emperor now as of right
now in the show the Empire has fallen
after the Battle of Endor in the battle
of jakku what remained of the Imperial
fleet has since gone into the unknown
regions and they're in the process of
becoming the first order so they're
nowhere to be found
The Imperials that we see on the
Mandalorian are just the leftovers who
are vying for power now the moths the
Admirals trying to consolidate what's
left of the Empire the way Werner
Herzog's character refers to it and he's
wearing him Imperial medallion is bring
back a sense of order go back to the way
things used to be under imperial rule we
know that the Emperor had all kinds of
secret projects all over the galaxy
hidden from the rest of the Empire he
was obsessed with immortality Q the
Darth Plagueis the wise speech and he
was obsessed with the knowledge of the
force that being said is much contempt
as he showed for Master Yoda
during branch of the Sith because Yoda's
race was so powerful in the force
Emperor Palpatine tried to learn
everything he could to exploit that or
in lieu of that kill all the other
members of his race top that would pop
up because they were potential threats
to him if every member of Yoda's race is
just as force-sensitive as he was and
capable of being just as powerful it's a
huge threat to the Empire when Palpatine
seemingly died which we know now didn't
stick because he just showed up in the
flesh during the rise of Skywalker
trailer a lot of these secret projects
that the Emperor was working on sort of
burst at the dam because he wasn't there
to keep them secret anymore
so a lot of people working on those
projects or who had knowledge of them
tried to exploit them in his absence now
a lot of people are wondering if dr.
Pershing is either going to try and
clone baby Yoda to make an army of force
sensitive beings that the remnants of
the Empire are able to use to maintain
order a bunch of evil tiny Yoda's
running around with lightsabers or it
baby Yoda himself is a clone of Yoda is
part of that attempt after watching the
episodes a couple times I'm starting to
think less that he's an actual clone of
Yoda but that they do want to clone him
and the reason that he's a foundling
just like the Mandalorian is because he
lost his parents they were killed
sometime between the prequels in the
original trilogy during the purge if
he's fifty years old
that makes them about as old as Anakin
Skywalker so baby Yoda predates the
prequels
the mandalorian took the job dr.
Pershing insisted that he be brought
back alive and that probably has
something to do with the viability of
the cloning process like living
biological matter is easier to clone
than dead matter the reason why Werner
Herzog's character is totally cool with
him being dead is probably because
either doesn't care about this army of
clones Oda's or he doesn't think they'll
be able to control them there been a lot
of jokes about Yoda maybe getting with
ya doll but the thing is is that even
though they're male and female members
of their species and they reproduce like
normal mammals would with male and
female the reason why I don't think that
baby Yoda is actually Yoda's biological
child is because Yoda made such a big
deal about the tenets of the Jedi Order
and one of the core ones was that they
were never allowed to have children so I
think at least Master Yoda would have
respected that
yato left the Jedi Council after Phantom
Menace she might still be alive like I
said she's mentioned during Star Wars
fall in order by someone thinking that
she's still alive after the great purge
after order 66 but that hasn't been
confirmed yet because of George Lucas
keeping them secret nobody really knows
much about their race not in real life
and not within the Star Wars universe
like the other Jedi Masters and
historians don't know much about Yoda's
race themselves because of their in
fibia slight qualities we know that they
come from very swamp like planets like
Dagobah was the perfect planet for Yoda
to hide on one because it helped mask
his force signature because it was so
strong in the force they just sort of
drowned his signal out so that the
emperor couldn't find him but it also
served his biological needs for his race
because he needed to live in a swamp
like environment we know they're
extremely long-lived
but because of that they reproduce very
infrequently and they're always very
very few of them in the galaxy at any
one time there's no actual count even
Master Yoda probably doesn't know how
many members of his race currently exist
but when they're born they're all born
with relatively high force sensitivity
so if you do want to talk about
midi-chlorians yes do you mean you can
make all the jokes that you want but
they're all born with relatively high
counts just like Master Yoda was that's
why everyone is always so curious about
them the Emperor the rest of the
Imperials baby Yoda even tries to heal
the Mandalorian with the force just to
give you an idea for how innately force
sensitive and powerful he is he's not
old enough to speak but he knows enough
about the force that he knows that he
can use it to heal his wound even though
the Mandalorian himself seems like he
doesn't know anything about the ways of
the force
even if he grew up during the Clone Wars
which we know he did because of the
flashbacks my assumption there is that
because his parents seem like they were
killed during the Clone Wars and he went
into refuge he became a foundling as
part of these Mandalorian clans that
they just didn't spend a lot of time
teaching him about Force Lord because
most of the Jedi got wiped out during
the purge him learning about the force
by watching baby Yoda do crazy WTF
things will probably just play out over
the rest of the season
and if baby Yoda is doing stuff like
this now at the beginning of the series
think about what they might be saving in
terms of big WTF force moments for the
series finale if you're really excited
about what's going on with the series
right now don't worry they just started
filming season two a little while ago so
unless they say something different I'm
assuming the season two episodes will
drop next year around the same time and
by that time most places around the
world will have access to Disney Plus so
you won't all have to race around to
find the episode somewhere else every
single week when they drop them my
Mandalorian episode 3 video will post
tomorrow after the episode airs so be
sure to watch it however you can watch
the episode while you wait for that
everyone click here for my Star Wars
Mandalorian episode 2 video and click
here for my brand new Rick and Morty's
season 4 episode 3 trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]